Okay. So, we've seen four vans.
That one was the worst of all of them, by far.
It was really pretty but the rust was eating away in it,...
...so you could barely even open the door without really putting your back into it.
So, I think that's no.
I think we would really want the one thing I was so bad at filming yesterday,...
...the first van we saw yesterday.
It's really nice.
It's the only one that we've seen that has its TUV and its old-time papers.
So, I feel like just because of that alone,...
...the paperwork has bogged us down so much, to get to even to this point,...
...the thought of trying to do more paperwork, seems crazy.
And also that's the only car that's being driven right now.
It's hers.
It's Vera's car, the second one.
But, the timing on that one is not ideal.
She really wants to keep it till the end of September,...
...and we feel like we've been waiting to start this journey for so long.
...the idea of waiting another three months just doesn't make any sense.
And we'd have to be building in the winter again.
Yeah. Then we still have to build after that.
So, it would be October, we start building...
...we're not gonna hit the road until who knows,...
...Christmas or something like that?
So, I think that Lou's gonna have to call her tonight, and work his charm,...
...and see if we can get her to change her plans a little bit